Oh
now I'm home in Norway I've been away
for a month training camp a trip to
Moscow and a big chess tournament in
Azerbaijan and let's let's have a little
review of what happened in that
tournament then first of all we have a
couple of guests here and let's hear
their opinion about the tournament in
Lhasa better let's start with with my
manager Espen well it started very well
excellent and then something happened
exactly
yeah I'm gonna explain my problem I was
actually in good shape before the
tournament my problem is that well I was
I started getting a bit sluggish I mean
my head was not working so well I think
it partly but was because of my long
game said it partly was because I was
working too much TV both long games and
on the chess board and afterward yeah I
was fortunate yeah I was there was there
were football games almost every night
there was the NBA playoffs and we were
watching different reality series as
well it was simply too much simply too
much and towards the end I tried to cut
some of that [ __ ] out and then my
brain started to work better again yes
because I after due to losses you have
the rest day and then you did something
physical again yeah that kind of helped
I'm afraid my behavior during the
football tournament was like less than
exemplary but at least I got some of the
aggression out I got to move around a
bit and just to get a positive
experience was important for me just to
win at something eat tennis or football
or cards or whatever ah
it helped quiet quite the base exactly
another good way to a good mood again
another particularly ready but it turned
out the next day that no general person
was in even worse shape than I was then
all ready for the next day against about
Nakamura I was pretty I was feeling
pretty ok I didn't play that well that
was exciting
it was definitely an exciting game and I
think from the point that I started to
screw up well after that I played pretty
well I set him some practical problems
and then after the trend turned both on
the clock and on the board it was very
difficult friend to to defend so I was
thinking afterward I saw that you said
that
Bishop t7 in the early middle game was a
mistake yeah yeah I was following the
game from home and actually liked the
game and like they like the move and
like the black position and everything
but to think that maybe the compared to
me because again it might have something
to do with my style but it felt that the
possible queenside expansion would not
give me much apart
weaknesses because his position is not
very active but he has a very solid
foundation this pawn structure is
extremely solid while mine is not that
solid so I need to I need to create
active play somewhere and it felt like
the queenside expansion was just going
to give me weaknesses and I really
needed that other night to be activated
because right now it's doing nothing I
was considering whether I can play in
the Kings side push eight five eight
four but again it's just seems to be
playing into his hands obviously I knew
that brought both practically and also
theoretically speaking wasting time on
this Bishop c8 97 is extremely risky but
I felt that I didn't have a particular
choice but by then but he considered he
continued to play energetically after
that then I made this moon knight d3
which was probably objectively dubious
but I felt that otherwise he would just
go Knight e3 I'm stuck with a stupid
ninth on g6 he'll go night at five night
before eventually maybe at five ninety
six and worries my counter play that's
that was my main problem it just seemed
like have you seen this when you played
ninety three that other of snow going
into ending I could say that in the
worst case I might well I was more
concerned that he would not trade Queens
and this continued the attack because
even though he's better after he trades
Queenston I felt with everything he's
spending so much time trying to find
something clearer and the fact that my
play is kind of easy I just pushed push
on the Queen side hope for the best
it's the trend has turned yeah and then
a bit disappointed with my game against
Kuryakin
I thought I'd found a good plan in the
opening but it turned out that just
didn't have enough time to to complete
the plan and and then and then I just
had to be careful yeah on the one hand
is well prepared but on the other hand
after all it's the Queen's Indian so
even if he is well prepared it's going
to be pretty safe for what yeah and then
of course against Raja both I was a
little bit worse then he screwed up at
one point allowed me to take him III
which was quite inexplicable to me and
then yeah in a way all the excitement
remained under the surface as I didn't
exact actually sacrifice not see for
anything but it's the kind of position
where you can maneuver for 20 moves try
to make try to get him to made some
small concessions and there's absolutely
no risk right now I should try and and
and search I mean follow all the options
and milk every little drop there is in
the position trying to win and I was
following it on Norwegian TV and there
the commentators they were the were a
few tricks there were drinks and I think
it's it shows that he just I mean he
spent a lot of time and energy trying to
defend it he didn't make his moves
immediately and that kind of goes to
show that it's not no it's not easy and
it's a kind of position where if you
have to make one concession then maybe
you have to make another
and then it suddenly it gets really
difficult he defended very well I have
to say in general Roger Bobb played very
well in that tournament yeah it's a 50%
today yeah but I mean he was closer to
plot score than - score and considering
the way he's been playing lately like
that was major the last game against
Caruana
that was a decide the tournament because
we were on equal score scores before
before that game but you know knew that
that draw would be enough I didn't want
to play for a draw I mean I don't play
for a cross so in the opening I mean
honestly I didn't know what his approach
was going to be if he I didn't think he
would go all out for for a win but I
didn't know if it was going to play the
most rorish lines either then when he
played this c5 well first of all I
didn't know what to play in the open
because I I'd been I couldn't sleep
today before I was time yeah I found
some then I was starting to think I was
really in an extremely creative mood if
I might if I may say so and then
secretly looked at like the most
creative move I think it was pretty
crazy
well I came up with that during the game
because my other idea didn't work but
when he played c5 I was thinking whether
I should take or go see for that I
thought c3 he does probably doesn't want
to play the the exchange because it
doesn't normally portora it looked like
it's a draw after he exchanged his own
on on d4 I mean I mean theoretically why
it's very slightly better because of its
extra movement the question is whether I
can make something make something of it
or not no but it will be along and then
he played d5 I mean I I
he would fly a move like Queen c7 or 96
just to keep the tension to defend the
pot and they'd found the porn and then
d5
I thought for a few seconds and then I
thought okay if I'm not going to take
the pawn that it's absolutely pointless
play this way he got some more
compensation than I'd thought
but yeah I played up waiting before the
tiger proline I think he missed a key
moment when he went f5 yeah that is a
natural move but it just makes such a
huge difference I'm stuck for the night
on d6 instead of d2 because the d2
Knight takes away squares for my monkey
ship and besides it's not that active
and I felt that even though he gets this
efore this at 483 it looked a bit scary
but it feels like I'm controlling a lot
of squares his Bishop on g7 is not
participating and all my pieces are in
some way participating in the defence my
knight can get quickly to eat to e4 my
queen you can get to be 43 and then of
course he missed this before yeah twice
but again it's it's not that hard to and
then the rest of the game is just fun
but all in all it was exciting five wins
in 10 games that that is a lot yeah it
was kind of a continuation of the style
of the candidates tournament a lot of
fighting chess sometimes two fighting in
the sense that some players may be
needed to family more carefully in some
games but definitely exciting test I
prefer to waiting five games and make
five drawers instead of winning five
games and losing twice obviously but it
was fun to win against and in the next
tournaments I'll try and still still
play aggressively while
while months getting into the such
difficult positions as I did in a couple
of against